meine Freundin hat letztens meine nassen
Haare gesehen und hat gesagt hey Vanessa
ich glaube du hast Block von mir selbst
hätte ich das nie vermutet weil guckt
euch meine Haare an das sind keine
Locken jedenfalls hat meine Freundin mir
einen Tool mitgegeben mit dem ich das
mal ausprobieren kann also lasst uns
gemeinsam rausfinden ob ich Locken habe
und dafür waschen wir erstmal die Haare
voll cool ich habe jetzt erstmal ein
ganz normales Kopfhaut Shampoo von Balea
man muss sich jetzt ja auch nicht gleich
die ganze Scheiße kaufen ne ja das
könnten schon locken sein und ganz
wichtig nur so die Haare trocknen okay
ins Handtuch trockene Haar eine kleine
Menge geben sind meine Haare noch nicht
aber ich gebe schon meine kleine Menge
rein Spülung die du nicht brauchst ist
so komisch die Stunde der Wahrheit ist
gekommen und jetzt erfahrt ihr warum ich
dieses Sieb brauche wie ein diffuser
beim Haare föhnen wirken keine Ahnung ey
ich habe vergessen ich muss das hier
noch Wasser auftragen
es ist so wie jetzt und das ist das
Ergebnis crazy ich habe wirklich Wellen
also Locken sind es nicht aber es sind
Wellen vielleicht habt ihr noch eine
bessere Technik schreibt sie mir gerne
in die Kommentare